we had Zachary here and I didn't know
the whole story behind even how Shazam
his name like I didn't I didn't realize
like how the gods fit into and
everything and I thought that was really
cool because I love mythology it was a
great idea yeah because they were the
Superman they were the superheroes of
2000 years ago yeah that was why people
told stories about them yeah they did
superheroy type things they'd come down
they swoop in they'd you know they'd um
save the day save the day but do other
naughty things yeah and um but yeah they
were the superheroes of the days I love
too that the characters that you played
you and your sisters it wasn't all bad
there was reasoning I like whenever you
hear the reasoning like the back story
yes yes it was very they're complex yes
not rooting for them but you're kind of
right yeah that's kind of wrong yeah
yeah they did a really good job and The
Sibling relate The Sibling Rivalry yeah
and we were one of your sisters is a
psycho
that's Lucy Liu yeah but she's not in
real life yeah no no no
we became the just we became sisters
yeah the minute we walked on set we just
bonded and we're just great great we are
we call each other sister now that's so
cool because it doesn't always work out
that way usually Kim you know chemistry
sometimes it's like weird yes yeah great
chemistry
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody